[Music]
in loophole news right here loophole is
the Chinese way submitted by JK
bodyguard
oh I'll bet you're bigger you want if
you're not bigger than me then go away
then you can't guard her body yeah half
the world's not better than you though
oh the world is bigger than you bigger
than her look I look unlike other people
I have this all the way another bus to
save your own ass I get it I want a good
I want a good rest of my life he was
just hanging out just husband very
quietly I know you can't work why for
the first time at home right hi what
good will you [ __ ] up so long a man
resorts to painting his backyard after
pressure from the city to keep it green
so he painted his long green I thought
that's what they were doing uh because
of the whole water a lot of people were
doing that you just paint it this made
the news oh okay oh let's talk about it
there and it must be important and it's
a very different story than what I'm
doing yes and then people wanted us to
talk about it it ain't a stupid color oh
maybe he's actual paint instead of the
powder that yours that'd be funny but no
he did he use that you just [ __ ]
spray-painted he spray-painted their
long green like what's scraping yeah
Spence no these grasping look yeah and
like doing it I'd be tired
let's hear I'll let him tell you even
better most guys gonna say to himself
with this idea of just painting it and
it's not house paint it is
environmentally friendly paint stuff
they use on golf courses and football
fields and see that I've just painted
straight over the dirt in some spots for
what I would have spent in one month of
watering I could do this two or three
times the city's getting on his case cuz
his grass is getting [ __ ] up and it's
messing up the value all around him
people complain well he's not the only
one they did mention that to they'd say
Oh
they've gotten notices about the lawns
is their job there's this code that they
have to enforce must water code you know
I thought I got one of those citations
before during the drought no not during
the job this is when my mom first bought
her Monterey Park house and I was
supposed to be in charge of taking care
of it yeah I'm you're the work I know
when I was living in the front with my
friend and we were like 19 and I didn't
hire a line line long more to come I'm
not long hire I hire a gardener to come
and it started growing like all over the
place and at that time I that's dog
named Tyson and I'll just chain them to
the front the second Tyson I would have
them change with our front like little a
handrail thing so he would be [ __ ]
all over the place here I'll have big
brown spots and the parts that were
green were like this tall oh my god and
then someone ratted on our house and
that's like hire a lawn mower person to
come and because it was constructing all
the time the students get up after the
construction this guy's ghetto if I
wasn't in his life he [ __ ] his house
would be [ __ ] my parents were the
[ __ ] they had a [ __ ] junkyard for
the far backyard like we they put
everything back there like dead old
toyota 4runner back there that's a
Mexican [ __ ] they had a [ __ ] trailer
they had a [ __ ] WI playing parked in
the front lawn that just my complaints
all grew over it yeah and then they
would get notices from the city and it
was like and they're just like [ __ ] the
city we're doing this [ __ ] and then and
they apparent neighbors oh yeah and then
our neighbors would get pissed and this
was all during like that when like 2000
[ __ ] eight like my dad like his
business went south and and so they
ended up and the economy was [ __ ] and
so like my parents they didn't really
know what to do about any of this [ __ ]
and so the neighbors would send notices
all the time be like yo we can't sell
our house cuz your [ __ ] things
ruining our property was it the front
one it was it was both yeah
when I met him it was still like that
and then during the downturn and you met
me during those two like we had part of
our whole house like our garage in two
rooms like we shared it with like a
Mexican family well they like sectioned
it off so that like that's resourceful
yeah and so they the guy like Freddy and
his family lived with my family and it
was could have sold all that junk and
made a little money that was the whole
time
but your mom they're Muslim no she my
mom is a hoarder and she doesn't sell
[ __ ] anything because everything has
a memory including the [ __ ] old
toyota 4runner that was my uncles oh wow
even now what have you sent her on V now
what did you send her on vacation and
sell everything we tried to do that a
couple times actually my my son-- sister
was like you cannot do this and she
would cry
well they ended up having to move out of
there because my grandpa died and they
had to move my grandma and they're
taking care of my grandma and so all
their possessions right now we're in a
bunch of storage containers and it's
just like they push the can't they kick
the can down the road they're just
paying monthly rent to start off they
pay monthly rent like B fee monthly rent
because they got a [ __ ] huge like one
of those shipping container things - oh
my friend actually lived on a junker
like his family their house was there
like that's fine and then yeah they're
like yeah like their their house was
there but it was like a small one and
then his her dad was a mechanic so he
would work out there and then all this
[ __ ] was it was so cool because we would
pretend that we're like a biker gang or
whatever we ride the broken motorcycles
it was really cool make sure the yard
from all the Sandlot
oh yeah where they played baseball the
neighbor's yard where the ball overgrown
oh yeah yeah kind of it was it was a
small way it wasn't the big one we'd get
lost in it was just like imagine like a
property like a nursery sighs oh that's
not like me thank you Jace but yeah it
was it was cool too because the dad just
let us [ __ ] play I don't know [ __ ]
up but it was all good have you got some
told memories
yeah well cuz my parents let me out here
they weren't afraid of the world if you
just let the kid out
they have memories I don't know dude I
used to got in the blizzards and I come
back like later at night and I'd just be
sledding with my friends all day and my
parents didn't give a [ __ ] yeah we did
well they didn't your mom you told me
your mom yelled at you for that but -
it's not like she grounded me I like
never could do it again it was like it
was like you should really come back or
mom but it was like no big it's a pretty
resilient
yeah mine was a sunset rule I had to be
backed by like street lights on or
sunset - street lights but also my
parents it was so safe growing up in
Japan they didn't know how [ __ ] up
America was especially in LA yeah they
just didn't know and I think for them
like it was mainly my grandma that was
home and taking care of me and she
didn't know either so she was just like
yeah we would always play outside go
outside go outside with your friends
have fun my mom also didn't let me out
of like certain streets they got to stay
within that territory but since I knew
like okay if I have to be home within
three hours and it takes my 30 minutes
to go all the way over here and there in
its back that I didn't I expected that
planning like yeah this dude would be
like oh it's time it's time for me to be
home I should go now
well he probably didn't get his ass
[ __ ] beat every time he was off time
you see did you hear his story his mom's
good hey you should really be back here
what I does why yeah I got my house what
if my dad was home I'd be [ __ ] home
immediately oh but you know how to plan
it out oh yeah my dad was almost like no
no no but if my mom some of those she's
way more chill
she's softer so I'm gonna ask does it
really for free homeowners looking at
you - and you - okay does it really
devalue the house if your neighbors
grass is not is dead that's an icky
question well we are we live in a condo
so no but if you do you know the house
rules though like if you live in the
street oh yes it does so what how they
measure your home how they measure
home's value is one it's based off of
like the property and then what your
home has like bathrooms bedrooms
whatever but then the other one that's
takes priority is called comps and it's
like a comparable sell so whatever your
most recent comparable
and that neighborhood is what highly
dictates what your house is so if one
house looks really really [ __ ] up then
when they start comparing cops like that
one it really drastically lowers how
much your house can be sold for they
actually don't want you to sell your
house cheap no so like if your block you
have that one [ __ ] that doesn't take
care of its lon
if that person gets that they and the
buyer is flipping it and renovates that
makes it look nice and that makes their
property value better and then everyone
likes that yeah everyone likes that even
with like business property to is same
[ __ ] oh yeah like the plaza has to be
fixed up or even like where our gym is
right now like the are neighbors like
our tenant or our landlord wants us to
rent that other side they're a sweatshop
yeah well I mean they're running it - it
just looks like [ __ ] it does Oh what did
they move out are they still there no
they're still there but I see a bunch of
Asian ladies come out with cigarettes
[ __ ] just flicker them all over the
place yeah and there's trash Edie and
it's like literally next door I used to
work next to the C cane See's Candies
and it was a bunch of Asian ladies who
were like smoking in the thing and
almost walking into traffic every day
because they were like [ __ ] life apply
for she's candy now so when I was in
high school they man I got to get a job
in alright like chocolate me bill or
Cassie's candy when I went there to get
a job application or okay cool fill this
out when you come back for the interview
we're gonna test you on these forty
chocolates I just had an application
right back
how's that No thank you I'm not gonna
[ __ ] memorize forty chocolate tastes
all the chocolates yeah that was too
much over you have to remember that look
dad
[Music]